aoc says it's inevitable that texas will
turn blue this is an insider story okay
aoc made the claim saturday during the
campaign style for progressive
candidates jessica cisneros and greg
sasar
running for primaries for texas 35 35th
congressional district against
democratic lawmaker lloyd delgade
cisneros is running in the state 28th
congressional district against another
democratic lawmaker representative henry
sulad here's what's exciting about
jessica's race and greg's race is that
if we flip texas we flip the country
texas turning blue is inevitable
inevitable it will happen the only
question is when city aoc we are going
to fight for living wage as a minimum
wage we're going to make sure we
unionize the hell out of the state we're
going to make sure that we confront
corrupt industries and lobbyists and big
money said aoc will that ever happen
in texas not not in the way that she's
thinking for a simple fact that i think
democrats as i said earlier have done
such damage to themselves with latino
and hispanic american communities
i mean i'm old enough to remember 20
years ago when people said that florida
was going to go blue it would never come
back look at the diversity that we have
in florida look we have all these uh
people from uh central and south
american countries people coming from
africa and other countries from all over
the world there's no way that's going to
just stay this this red state well guess
what uh many of the people who are
coming to florida support freedom they
support democracy who are people to your
point earlier about laws and you know
one who really respects laws in america
immigrants why because in some of the
countries where they came from they
didn't have the rule of law that was
something that maybe they had in america
so the success story that you've seen
with um
latinos and hispanic americans in
florida i think also the damage that
democrats have done in texas will make
it tougher now obviously they're not
monolithic communities so it's that we
have not had the same movement
we haven't had quite the same movement
with uh say mexican americans we have
would say cuban americans but i think uh
aoc's uh taking a little uh too much of
a tunnel vision on this one i don't
think quite accurate could at some point
a democrat win in the state of texas uh
look i mean you can never say like never
that's indefinitely the rest of it but
do i think that the state's ultimately
going to trend to become blue not
necessarily not with the way that
democrats have turned a blind eye to but
it has been trending
no doubt but
what has changed and trends are tough to
break but what has changed the trend is
the democrats embrace of blm and you
look at that rio grande valley seat uh
that flipped there was a very strongly
uh democratic seat that we won uh along
with trump in 2020. here's the thing i
was on the phone yesterday with um along
with president trump we were talking to
someone who we'll just say they're high
up in uh uh congressional stuff and
we're talking about texas there's a seat
there's a democrat plus 10 district plus
10 usually like in the three to five
range even on a good year maybe it's in
play maybe if there's a kind of a tidal
wave d
plus 10
that republicans are targeting and the
reason being because they think the
hispanics are going to flip so much
against biden and against the democrats
that it's actually in play
that dynamic but what i don't know is
how much of that is kind of the city is
that in
um
with beyonce they don't remember the
exactly if you look at the map of texas
you look at any major city that they
voted blue dallas houston san antonio
well adam look at look at this bottom
right here on the map on the tv it's all
blue right and what is that right up
against it's up against the border we're
having we're gonna have two plus million
immigrants come into the country this
year alone imagine this keeps going
hispanics do not like
hispanics that live here don't like the
illegal immigration because they know
what it does to their jobs they know
what it does to their wages etc etc when
is that map from this is from 2020. this
is okay this is before the immigration
this could it'll be interesting to see
what happens in 2022.
it's a lot of red right there but we'll
see but look at the popular vote i mean
it's it's neck and neck it's it's eight
six percentage points yeah i mean even
when beto went against ted i watched
that debate i mean that was a close call
between those two guys you know and and
ted should have lapped the guy yeah but
it's and beto just flipped his stance on
guns on second amendment because he he
understood that it was close he thinks
he can win texas they think they can
flip texas but 2022 texas is going to be
a bellwether yeah you can never say
never but in the short term at least the
next two four years uh i i don't see it
moving as fast as aoc would like i think
uh aoc may be uh uh she she probably has
better success in south florida uh she
likes south florida likes hanging out
she likes affordable a lot a lot and you
would agree if uh texas flips that's
that really hurts the republicans
chances oh yeah i mean yes because they
know small little oh well you might but
it's not
finished it's not in a in a vacuum you
look at the way that uh say wisconsin
michigan pennsylvania have all shifted
further to the right in the last two
presidential races uh those those had
not been contested states in some 20 25
years and now they're viewed as toss-ups
florida got two more republican by the
way just so you know florida went up two
more republican which means the florida
state matters more now than it did a
year ago two years ago three years ago
four years ago it's going in the
direction of those who like to be free
those who like to have jobs those who
like to pay low taxes those who like to
be left alone those who like
uh crypto with the guys we had at the
house yesterday told god knows one time
talking about meta and nfts and all
these different things florida's uh
florida's got some good strategies good
things going for themselves i just hope
texas fights to keep that going because
i think
i want to say
51 or 52
of fortune 500 companies headquarters is
in that state that's a lot of states the
only one beating them
is new york city new york's the only
state that has more
fortune 500 companies headquarters than
it does there i think silicon valley is
competing for that as well with texas so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]